on ignore encore les circonstances
exactes de cette collision entre un
poids lourd et un véhicule léger ce
matin sur l'a36 à hauteur de marchaux en
direction de besançon
le camion a tiré sur la droite pour
l'instant n'ont pas pu accéder à la
cabine puisque c'est impossible
il a tapé dans une buse d'évacuation le
tracteur a tapé dans une buse
d'évacuation de l'eau des eaux
et puis ça a eu pour effet de le lui
faire faire un tonneau et dans la
dans même moment il ya un véhicule
léger qui est arrivé qui c'est qu'à
taper la semi remorque elle chargement
est tombé sur le véhicule léger donc on
déplore donc un décès d une personne
décédée dans le
dans le transport hockey et puis une
personne blessée dans la voiture légère
la conductrice blessée bloqué dans son
véhicule était consciente à l'arrivée
des secours la circulation a été
interrompue pour plusieurs heures encore
avec sortie prévue par baume les dames
et mise en place d'un basculement de
chaussée avec approvisionnement en eau
pour les automobilistes
retenu dans un bouchon de 4 km